il est là pour garder le cap il est là
pour protéger avec fermeté et garantir
la sécurité de ses citoyens les taux ce
qu'il cherche à dégager c'est celui d'un
homme fort d'un homme d'action certes je
suis ouvert au dialogue mais si toi en
face du sort du cadre je te pulvérise
abilio diniz
tombeau de nick george et
moi je crois que messi
moutinho vrai nous n'avons pas affaire
ici à un tribun donc la rhétorique de
poutine elle est certainement liée à sa
personnalité mais plus encore à l'image
d'un dirigeant qui a construit une image
d'homme providentiel
est celle d'un homme qui construit une
narration de lui même sur le fait qu'il
a repris les choses en main après
l'échec dramatique de l'ère eltsine
histoire est très motivé délicat
théorique knox je l'ignoré idéologues
and sisters 10 octobre à dire juin près
de wenzhou est assailli scrooge il
estime
donc les taux ce qu'il cherche à dégager
c'est celui d'un homme fort d'un homme
d'action et qui joue à la fois sur la
fermeté et sur le fait de disputer de
manière ouverte et pour ce faire la
sémantique qui l'utilisent c'est celle
d'un homme de bonne volonté d'un homme
qui aurait subi une certaine manière une
déception qui seraient victimes de la de
la perfidie des partenaires
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui le pousse à voir
des affirmations comme nous serons
forcés de répondre ce n'est pas de notre
faute si nous sommes dans l'obligation
deux
ans
il n'y ait
absolument
antiterroriste a crû de 6 à
12 ans revenait à vis des lignes pas
secouer une ferme journée amiens canal
dispose du cash et naturaliste alou de
reach est il ait pas de célébrer mois
oui silhouette résultats tirés au pire
ou s'il est il utilise donc souvent un
procédé qui est le suivant tout d'abord
un syllogisme commence par un constat
voilà ce qui devait se passer ensuite
voilà ce qui s'est passé est
généralement il a recours ensuite elle a
au procédé rhétorique de la question
rhétorique 1ce ce premier temps et
donner le deuxième est donnée ensuite
que devrions nous faire qu'est ce que
vous feriez vous à ma place si vous
étiez dirigeants de la russie c'est un
peu de cette façon là qui le laisse
sous-entendre que il y a une légitimité
dans son action puisque c'est lui qui
est finalement la grécité housewives a
chaussé les lignes at donc je te
natanyahou trop
nombreuses et all inks internet
et
donc poutine se place quand même aussi
sur le registre si vous voulez de
l'éthique de la parole donnée j'ai
rempli ma part du contrat ça n'est pas
votre cas où vous en tirez donc les
conséquences et il prédit en quelque
sorte ce qui va se passer afin de
renverser le rapport de force ce nous
sommes forcés est alors agrémenté par un
vocabulaire qui devient généralement
plus offensif cette idée de nous sommes
forcés mais nous ne nous laisserons pas
faire et nous ne ferons pas preuve de
faiblesse
comme google
cette salle économique jusqu'aux voies
situées à thorigné beaudottes n'ont ni
bout de tous jeunes âgés sont restés
mexique da nadio genas moi je me suis
bien the city glande thyroïde bizarre
parce nous précise qu'elle finira cio
grâce à un but in fait alors appel et
usent du discours épidictique il fait
appel à des sentiments qui sont les
sentiments patriotiques du peuple russe
et dans lequel ce discours est politique
il y à 1 1 et 1 nous les agresseurs d'un
côté et les agressés prêt à devenir des
martyrs de l'autre et ce discours
épidictique y construit sa trame sur un
récit collectif nous que l'occident le
fameux e on nous pousse à la faute on
nous pousse à faire ceux ci
souhaiteraient dévié de sa trajectoire
et là dedans et bien il utilise un
registre comme nous l'avons dit ah c'est
assez simple peut imager qui se cantonne
à une description de la situation et qui
ne rechigne pas à utiliser parfois une
certaine forme d'humour
ni poster of not
[Applaudissements]
taquet liste mais bien pour chelsea
je n'aime pas la touche tab n'a
sabbatique yatta près du landeron ne
on retrouve aussi chez poutine et dans
son vocabulaire des moments où il passe
se révéler plus menaçant je ne nie
pas
le panier compagnies
dites vous
que je dise tiens notre nouveau tout
comme les animaux se voyait volet
il y à là si vous voulez une sorte de
radicalisation de la rhétorique du e et
d'une ou de l'ami et de l'ennemi en
politique qui est un objet évidemment
souvent utilisé dans la rhétorique
politique et à plus forte raison
lorsqu'on se trouve dans un conflit armé